bismillah alhamdulillah peace be unto
you you are watching the Deen show every
Wednesday midnight's Thursdays 2 p.m.
here in Chicago on Kent TV 36 if you
don't have and if you're not here with
us in Chicago people from all around the
globe are tuning in to the Deen show
calm we're trying to hear we're trying
humbly to help you understand the most
misunderstood way of life yet the
fastest-growing way way of life in the
world today Islam that way of life that
was brought by all the messengers of God
they all call people to the same way to
surrender and to submit not to the Sun
to the moon not to Jesus not to Muhammad
but the one who Jesus Muhammad and all
the messengers of God submitted to the
one who created the Sun the moon he
created man and woman but he's not a man
or woman the creator of the heavens and
the earth and Arabic we say Allah so
we're here trying to help you understand
this beautiful way of life and one of
the most beautiful things in Islam is
finding your soulmate but there are some
things that we need to know about how to
get married how to approach that special
someone to certain do's and don'ts and
my next guest who's coming out Yasser
Bajaj Sheikh al-sabah jaws is going to
help answer some of these questions so
you don't want to go nowhere we'll be
right back
how much is his messenger Allah not you
know him
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamo allaikum sheer waalaikumsalam
with a la Monica how are you handling
good to see you one more time good to
see you again thank you for being with
washing thank you very much for having
me here how's everything on the road you
travel a lot nowadays I do actually I do
a lot a lot things are going very well
our house shake Wally boo suni Yasir
Qadhi how are they doing good to see
them often alhamdulillah we don't really
get to see each other very often we
communicate to handle a lot yeah I
really enjoyed working with them and I
enjoy working with you and I'm glad that
you you can be with us we have some
questions people can go to your own
section at the Dene show calm they can
read a little bit about you your
biography and some of the work that
you're currently involved in you're an
instructor with Al Maghrib Institute is
this correct yes sir and you have a site
that helps people you trained people and
helped get them ready for marriage I
practice yes yeah so they can find all
the information there at the Dene show
calm you'll click on your pajamas
picture there and everything will come
up now we were talking about the last
time about the proper way to approach
that man and woman now people can go
back and look at that show we're going
to continue on talking about some of
these relevant questions that people
have so we're going to just get right
into some of the questions that I have
are you ready all right let's go for it
now the next question that we have is
how do you progress getting to know
assistant when you're not sure if you
want to propose to her you want to talk
or interact with her to get a sense of
who she is before you make any type of
proposal that you might regret mm-hmm
well the issue of again going to propose
and how much you should know about a
person and so on it's very confusing
here in this inven and the most I would
say talented community
the intelligence community yeah many
people they think that you should know
everything about the person before even
married yeah what I found statistically
speaking you know surveying so many
young men and women on campuses and
different communities and so on is that
those who are pursuant to know the
person and they try their best you know
almost everything about them yeah at the
end of the road they become less
interested on them mhm
the more they know about them and that's
ironic
the more they know about them the less
they become interested in them which
separa it seems that that the subject of
knowing the person or list for marriage
it's what makes it so beautiful it's
being a mystery means you'd like it's a
kind of mystery and that's why people
sometimes in this culture they did for
months years and then eventually they
they stopped everything they break up
it's basically confusing because for
some people when you you know simply
just start try to think to know that to
know the person before you officially
engaged to them and suddenly right now
it's completing the opposite it defeats
the purpose
so my recommendation suggestion for the
person is they need to know enough about
that individual that they would like to
propose to until there is the comfort
zone yeah reaching comfort zone it means
that you feel okay with it mhm
you don't have to know every single them
about them before you propose yeah you
first know that they're willing to
cooperate on certain levels yes a day if
they are available or not if they think
that they're ready for marriage or not
if they can consider someone like your
status basically they know that the
person was proposing is from a different
perspective background and so on you
know once you reach the the the comfort
zone or that level then you go and
propose to know right now they're
intellectuality their level of let's say
maturity how much what is what are their
goals for life and so on these things
will come as you converse and you
communicate with each other and the
first proposal does not necessarily mean
that's going to be accepted or rejected
yeah you just simply you go and you talk
to them and you converse and see explore
basically the mind and the heart of
individual that you propose them next
question that would lead me into would
be is it allowed permissible
for a man and woman to talk over the
Internet meaning chat email in order to
get to know one another better for
marriage if this basically if this is
after the initial proposal means they
proposed means the parents they know or
at least if they don't have let's say
someone has does not have a parent being
the convert or maybe someone whose
parents might not be of any interest
basic into their relationship or
marriage and so on they still need to
have some kind of protection so that
they don't get let's say carry on away
with that relationship without pro forma
maybe arrangements for the future and so
on
so my recommendation I would say it
really depends depends on the approval
of the parents or their garden or the
what is what engage or also involve into
that into that proposal yeah if it was
before the proposal I do not really
recommend that at all
because you basically going to be
consuming your energy with someone over
the Internet
that you might even have seen at all
email just seen pictures maybe they are
over the sea maybe we are just in across
the country and its really really
consuming when it comes to exploiting
your emotion and their emotion for know
maybe I would say logical reason because
engaging anytime soon might be a kind of
a dream you have nothing of reality so
it's going to be really confusing so I
don't recommend that so if you're gonna
be communicating online chatting is not
the best way of doing that rather
probably have been approval again of the
Guardian it might be over the phone
where they can speak and they can at
least hear you know what's going on or
they're going to be exchanging emails
then someone needs to BCC to make sure
that you know all the conversation I'll
be taken seriously you know for the
purpose of that conversation it's not
just a matter of you know hanging out
and just you know feeling the love and
sensation and so on no it's about
someone who's serious about this
relationship who wants to take it to the
next level which is engagement and then
marriage so if I understand it correctly
first is the proposal or the intent to
propose saying okay look we're doing
this because I want to get married so
then we go on from there absolutely it's
not that like someone who's just going
around checking you know all these let's
say ladies in the community or a lady
for example trench shake and all the
guys in the community and now they want
to explore one at a time one
no you need to have that genuine into
interest if you know someone you have
seen someone by sight and you just feel
comfortable with that with that
individual that's when you go and you
start asking other people like we said
in the previous actually program so that
you go and you asked you have someone
could bring you some more information
and then when you reach your comfort
zone that's when you go and you propose
and if the proposal was initially
approved you starts communicating with
each other to know more what do you need
to know you need to know what but just
basically
helps you make a decision knowing
everything is almost impossible as a
matter of fact even man even regardless
how much you think you know that person
even if you were let's say practicing
dating the conventional dating you know
even if you do that for months and years
and so on
eventually the true aim at the true
color of the individual appears after
marriage yeah and we have the perception
that you know you get to know the person
before you get married but statistically
speaking the rate of divorce in America
is so high about 60% anymore which means
one out of I mean six out of ten
marriages into the divorce and you're
talking about culture that promotes
dating so much meaning you need to know
the person so again this kind of you
know process does not guarantee
happiness in marriage even if you love
the person damn much before does not
guarantee happiness after man so
marriage has its own rules and therefore
regardless how much you think you've
preferred for it you might be surprised
and you will all be surprised you think
people are confusing and saturation lost
with now love there is absolutely I
would say I agree that there is some
kind of confusion here many people they
just get attracted to the image yeah and
they have the full right you get attract
to the image because we believe that the
image is that the eye basically is that
the Gateway to the heart
yeah and beauty is a sign of perfection
so for people when you see something
beautiful you to say or something
perfect whether it says something you
know sophisticated like technology or
even design whatever you go you say it's
beautiful even though it has nothing to
do with beauty it's just even a piece of
metal but the first sophistication of it
and the perfection of that design makes
it beautiful so in our perception beauty
the sign of perfection so when you see
someone that you consider beautiful
or handsome then a new perception he or
she must be perfect yeah
regardless and you start deceiving
yourself that you know what everything's
gonna be okay because they're beautiful
because they're perfect they are nice
they're good and so on that's
infatuation you're trying to close your
eyes close your ears from listening you
know to the to the reality of life means
marriages is beyond just the sensation
of love and so I know many people grow
up and we all grew up on that act
reading fairy tales and beauty lovers
and so on which makes things you know it
just ends always with happily ever after
and so on I wish that the reality is
like a fairy tale but it's not yeah so
there's so much needs to be done and its
contribution to actually individuals in
a relationship to make it successful
next question here we have is how do you
reconcile beauty and Dean Dean
translated is the way of life for
religion if he or she's not very good
looking then you won't want to be with
her or him but if she's not on the Dean
yeah same situation I agree
actually the first thing the first thing
which comes to beauty we need to realize
that the beauty is a relative issue
mm-hmm it's in the eye of the beholder
yeah the 21st century culture has made
many people assume love of a specific
standard so you watch TV you read
magazines you get you know to go to the
street and so on people are obsessed by
specific image they made a standard of
beauty and that's that our beauty is not
even reality why because it just you
know it's it's a creation our minds that
the imagination of our in our own minds
and it does exist in terms of you know
the image being available but it's not
for everybody yeah I mean if everyone is
going to wait for that mr. and mrs.
perfect to be there you're gonna be
waiting for so long yeah and even if you
do that you have seen so many people
what they do they try let's say to start
a conversation with someone whom they
assume to be handsome a woman who will
choose who's beautiful but after some
time they get disappointed even though
she's beautiful even though he's
handsome but unfortunately in terms of
intellectually they're not mature and
demonstrative spirituality they're not
showing that kind of dedication devotion
to Allah subhanAllah
Lord and so on so they get turned off so
it's no longer just a matter of beauty
again beauty isn't I have the beholder
some people they look into the spiritual
beauty which is the Deen thing yeah so
when people they look into the Deen
means the practice of the Dean and
religion for them it's a sign of
devotion if they can't devote themselves
to their Creator they can devote
themselves and themselves to the
creation that their husband their wives
in this case yes and even the prophets
Allah some recommended guidelines he
says Allah Jacquemont Arbonne adeana
hula-hula call for the would you which
means if someone comes to you someone
comes to you with a proposal and you're
satisfied with their Deen and Allah
which means their religion their faith
the level of worship and a lock which
means mannerism so two things are would
guaranteed a level of I would say
happiness and stability in the marriage
with other dynamics of course the merge
would help too as well but here this is
not to initiate that the first thing is
Dean when we say Dean we mean by that
the practice of their faith that is that
that's an indicator to the the sound
relationship with the creator then you
have a last lock which means mannerism
that's the indicator to their
relationship with the creation so you
need to look at two things
how's the relationship with their Lord
and what's the relationship would the
his creation mean the people around him
do they behave well not people they know
how what you know about them is that
they do they have a good reputation a
good let's say character and so on so
it's a matter of basically their
relationship with the Lord and the
character with the people that's what
define to you the basics yeah and then
people they have other preferences
afterwards of course you know the issues
the level of beauty the level of
intelligence a level of let's say
lifestyle and so on that is something
optional people they adjust their
priorities dependent on their own you
know taste next question asks how can
one know that the girl will accept the
leadership role of the husband if she is
also working and possibly making more
money than mm-hmm that's an issue that
creates some stress and in relationships
really I mean in Islam it's absolutely
permissible for women to pursue Korean
pursue work and earn money as long as of
course she for specific guidelines in
terms of you know
the type of work she's doing and where
the money is coming from its permissible
source and so on when it comes to a
marriage men basically they look for a
woman and they have different also
preferences some men they might be
looking for a career woman because they
would like to have that specific life
standard and by them said they would not
be able to avoid to provide for that so
therefore they need their spouse to help
with this yeah some other people no they
won't like to have a traditional
lifestyle which means he wants to be the
breadwinner and in this case he he needs
his wife to just you know to take care
of the household and so he would like to
provide her with everything he wants to
be the man in her life and so on so
therefore they feel so proud of
themselves achieving that for their
wives and so on and someone they like
that as well yeah some women they do
that they don't like that and some of
them I know act you as a matter of fact
who are pursuing specific let's say
education and degrees and so on but
they're not not interested in in workin
with that degree they're just waiting
until someone proposed yeah so it goes
both ways but regardless of the
situation if someone is going to be
marrying someone of a different
perspective when it comes to marriage
then they need to have that cleared up
before they go officially with the word
marriage we need to clear up everything
okay I would like my wife example two to
work or I'd like my wife to stay at home
and I will take care of her I would do
everything for her Charlotte's Widow she
would never feel anything is missing in
her life and so on or maybe the man he
would like to his wife to help with that
so it's a matter of you know mutual
arrangements and in Islam there is a
room for there's a room for condition
stipulations before marriage
yeah what they what they agree on it
will of course have to go through
because that's a mutual agreement a
mutual consent but as a recommendation
though that's no that's something
different Islamic Lee speaking we
believe in traditional values it's the
man is the one who is providing for the
family and the woman she is basically
her role is so important in family no
man would be able to really substitute
for the role of women in family life and
that's what creates kind of stability in
society as well yeah so this is uh if if
now say the husband he really wants that
these children are raised by their
mother obviously and it's more important
that
really because she's the institution of
the children now absolutely that is it
something that is encouraged that now
she does make sure that her number one
priority is making that these children
grow up to be people who who contribute
to society and absolutely absolutely
unfortunately many people they
underestimate the value and and and I
would say the work even of women at home
when they take care of the children I
mean I'm married myself and I have three
children I know how much women how much
you know my wife she is basically she I
don't want to say they used the word
suffer but how much she really she
didn't use in order to make sure that
everything is being done for the family
for the kids and also for herself and
that doesn't mean that woman would
completely melt her personality her
character into the relationship you
still have her space though yeah she has
an own space sure I don't room to
breathe and to do things that she likes
to do and so on as long as it
permissible and so on you know
islamically that's okay but absolutely
that the best role is to take care of
the future generation of this Ummah and
also the future in issue of humanity you
know and that's not an easy job to do
she should look down I'm like someone's
looking down at her because it is they
society is painted it kind of like
you're with your house mom or this is a
big party role now people know they
think of this as you know you have a
second role in society yeah and that's
not fair I believe people unfortunately
there weren't you know beyond I would
say dealing with reality yeah and now
they're just living their own dreams of
doing the personal achievements and
goals and then they fall short on one of
these primary roles that you know woman
can do in life yeah which is taking care
of the family and the children and so on
that of course now here the thing that
comes over here okay would men ever be
appreciative to their wives you know the
sacrifice and so on the absolutely needs
to be appreciative as a man should
appreciate that his wife is the one
who's taking care of things you know in
the house and so on
and he should also understand you know
the agony is and the pain that his wife
might go through you know there's some
sometimes there's a communication
problem here yeah a man can't sometimes
you know express himself to his wife
properly and woman might speak let's say
in a language that the man might
understand
in terms of your feelings and emotions
so they started getting this kind of
clash yeah the man he thinks he's being
betrayed you know by not being
appreciated because of his sacrifice or
to the family and in return the woman
she also feels that the pain that you
know what or what I'm doing he thinks
he's the one who's doing everything but
I'm the one who's doing all these
sacrifices at home and so on both of you
are doing what they're supposed to be
doing their own role in life and the
last part that says and missle shikaka
reject women are counterparts for men
which means we complete each other we
don't we should not compete against each
other if we start competing we both lose
but if we start you know understanding
that my counterpart is on the other side
and therefore it just like becomes like
a piece of puzzle yeah you put them
together it becomes perfect because if
that home is broken and if the home is
not taken care of where these kids have
that love and mercy that first is
starting with that mother absolutely if
Betsy's taking care of the children and
the TV's raising them and then they're
going to be let out for society and
they're not going to obviously be a good
contribution absolutely you're gonna
have some problems we are doing already
having active problems because of this
unfortunately and I think the main
problem is in our perception that's you
know being a mother who takes care for
children that is not that value it's not
that a big contribution to the community
of the society so women they have they
grew up right now knowing you know that
I did to contribute something different
and do something else and so on and most
women they really do that with good
intentions that they would like to do
something for themselves feel specific
let's say self-worth into finding
especially a special thing that they can
do besides you know being just a mother
at home and so on yeah and I believe
that those who choose to be a
stay-at-home mom they're really they
deserve all the praise yeah because now
we're now talking about women who can
achieve things yeah anything besides you
know achieving the most important role
which is taking care of household and
the child at home if your OSAP because
there are so many questions and so
little time but we're obviously not
going to be able to get to all these
questions before we talk about this
website that you have and about training
and
helping people to find that soulmate
talk to us bring it home for the person
that might have just accepted this way
of life Islam and now they see all these
different rules of restrictions and
they're used to doing it their own way
according to their own desires holding
hands with a woman getting how am i how
am I supposed to get to know her how am
I supposed to you know realize if she's
the one I have to give her guardian I
have to do this have to do that seems
like a lot of weight now and how do you
bring it home and rationalize this and
help them to understand the wisdom
behind this
fortunately the Muslims those who come
to Islam I know they're one of the
things that they might face at the
beginning is that like a cultural shock
yeah I mean everything for them is
probably new and everything that they do
is probably for the first time so it's
going to take a while for them because
before they get adjusted to this kind of
thing specifically when it comes to the
interaction between men and women and
both of them when they act the act was
full with full you know with open heart
and you know with good faith and so on
it's not that the attendants do
something wrong
but just sometimes they don't know if
it's right or wrong to do it there is of
course a level of interaction between
men and women in Islam it doesn't mean
that you know men and women are
completely separate from each other yeah
there is a level of interaction but it's
this interaction is the formal
interaction the informal interaction
should be for the family and should be
with the spouses which means to you know
just let your guard down a little bit
and start acting yourself and so on that
would be between family members but what
those who are not related to each other
they would still have to be some level
of formality with full respects when a
man did with a woman he did will have an
equal mental level and I would say give
her that that the respect that she
deserves as a lady and the man same
thing he deserves also that respect this
is his privacy in his space as well and
the community is not a read to the woman
so we all complete we don't compete
against each other so if a man is
interested that's in a woman and he
would like to know how to do it we
should should go to her and say I would
like to get married to you or bend down
on his knee and so ask me I proposed you
this might not work in the idea you know
world of Muslim societies it has to go
through some of some of these I would
say trainings now this is where you
provide that's what we provide we also
provide that and shell out data we give
them techniques we give them tips and
how to do it how to go about it and they
are also on our blog which is the blog
for practice made calm when you go to
the blog there's a lot of interaction
and there are so many actually ideas
that we can bring to the table yeah and
we always ask for their contribution as
well because they have some concerns we
would like to know how we could really
help them so if they can provide us with
that kind of help would also provide the
best training that they want insha'Allah
that we have them so this would you can
say can you add to this what I'm saying
is that this is for the protection of
society for the protection of the men
and women I mean because we see what
happens when your desires run wild
most men are interested in one thing and
they can get let away by you know the
smooth talkers and the man whose agenda
is one thing so if you do it the way the
crater wants you to do it is for your
own protection that's not so you don't
end up having illegitimate children
diseases and all these other things that
have come why you that want to do it
your own way that's the importance of
marriage yeah we believe that the
marriage marriage the institution is a
sacred relationship yeah it was
mentioned of for us being so sacred yeah
so if it was sacred I mean no one has a
right you know to to mess up with it it
has specific guidelines and rules
they're not rigid rules yeah but they're
guidelines that can help you even ensure
a better relationship for yourself
family so it protects both actually men
and women the misperception is that it's
only protects men is really wrong yeah
this is more even protective it's more
protective to women than it is for men
yeah and men they also have their share
you know of responsibility as much as
they required that they're required to
receive their rights in the relationship
so when we look at it from from from all
sides we will see that's really a
perfect system yeah it's a really
perfect system that people would
definitely appreciate if they know that
true about the concept of marriage in
Islam so tell us where they can go to
get this training and where they can go
to hopefully God willing find their soul
mate I hope so and I wish them business
a lot Arabic um can visit us at our
website practise mate calm yeah and go
to our blog as well
which is what used to be the the
marriage Revolution calm and as that was
integrated into the same website so they
come and visit and they see for
themselves insha'Allah Allah they can
judge
we would like also to see the
contribution on the block the most
important thing right now to go start
explore it before you make a decision on
journey practice made or not go to the
block interact with other singles insha
Allah Allah and see how people they see
things differently men and women how
they see the subject of marriage
differently it's amazing
that would definitely will just open
your mind to the eye that you different
you're gonna need that kind of training
is all of that sheikh thank you very
much for being with us together on the
Dean show vehicle thank you and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the deans I hope you got the benefit and
it's very important it's very important
that we understand that this life is
short paradise seeing the face of our
Lord the one who created us this is what
we all should be striving for and having
your soul mate next to you makes things
a lot easier so we need to get on the
ball and find that right person the
Sheikh had given us a website that we
can visit or you can get that proper
training because this is one of the
biggest challenges facing us today it's
finding that special someone so you
train to get better at basketball you
get training to get better at your
profession why not get some training on
how to be the best spouse so please
visit that website and visit us here at
the Deen show com every week for a new
show until next time I said on alaikum
peace be unto you the DVDs for Dawa as
Allah has said in the Quran in surah now
16 125 we do in a severely deepika bill
hikmah to invite all to the way of your
lord with wisdom beautiful preaching and
reason with them in ways that are best
and this is a great opportunity for you
to take up the obligation take up the
call as Allah has told you to do and
share this beautiful message with the
world Islam submission to the one God
doesn't see what everyone's talking
about if you find one contradiction it
can't be from God
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for shipping guy that's why I
wouldn't never give up spreading this
message hope then you take that
necessary step you don't know if you're
gonna live till tomorrow so you got to
find that urgency to do the right thing
right now if you say that you do not
believe in Jesus you have stepped
outside of his name you cannot be a
Muslim is attended our faith to AIDS
come Italy everybody sleeping I arise
and ask a lot of thinking me Omar you
see all our you know all the things I do
I turn to you to forgive my sin tomorrow
I'm you sinful slave you don't my love
alone I'm the one runs away all the
guide me